things seem to be heating up in Kourtney  Kardashian's love life  [Music]  looks like God Disick isn't the only one  with a rumored new flame Kourtney is  keeping up with her eggs  Kourt was spotted in can with her  rumored boyfriend Yunus Benjamin yeah  the reality star also enjoyed soaking up  the Sun with her pal Simon Huck in a new  colored bikini on Monday night Kourtney  hit the town with the 24 year old model  she stepped out to got the night club in  a skin-tight cutout dress before Botox  caught her driving off with Yunus in his  car the pair's outing comes after Scott  was seen at LAX with Bella Thorne a  source told et Lord Disick and the  famous in love actress were headed to  can together no offense to you but no  matter what you do I can't change my  life over it  [Music]